[Musique]
et Jeanne d'Arc ça vous évoque quoi
alors Jeanne d'Arc c'est une partie de
notre histoire une jeune fille qui a qui
a fait la guerre contre les Anglais
c'était je pense qu'elle représente bien
la femme en disant qu'elle est utile
dans le monde quel que soit son âge quel
que soit son histoire quel que soit
parce que bon elle est partie de rien
elle venait de la campagne il y a un
mystère autour du personnage je pense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue à
Orléans au pied de la statue de Jeanne
d'Arc ville qui a dédié une rue à cette
figure féminine incontournable de notre
patrimoine ligérien
à 13 ans des voies célestes lui confie
la mission de chasser les Anglais de
France elle entre alors avec les troupes
françaises dans la capitale ligérienne
le 29 avril 1429 et libère la ville en
chassant les Anglais le 8 mai de cette
même année
[Musique]
d'abord condamné à la prison à vie pour
des fêtes telles que porter des
vêtements masculins ces prophéties ces
révélations divines elle sera finalement
brûlée vive à l'âge de 19 ans sur la
place du Vieux-Marché à Rouen
sa réhabilitation sera proclamée en 1456
par le pape Calixte 3 elle sera ensuite
béatifiée en 1909 et canonisé
[Musique]
Jeanne d'Arc est devenu une véritable
héroïne au point que la ville d'Orléans
la célèbre chaque année dans le cadre
des fêtes de Jeanne d'Arc qui ont lieu
ici même dans la rue qui porte son nom
depuis 1840
[Musique]
et nous arrivons maintenant devant une
institution orléanaise la chocolatière
un véritable pan de la mémoire de cette
rue Jeanne d'Arc puisqu’installer ici
depuis 30 ans et vous allez découvrir
que cette histoire de famille autour du
chocolat est aussi une histoire de
femmes
ok c'est beau merci de nous accueillir
Marylène et Laura dans votre belle
chocolaterie à Orléans rue Jeanne d'Arc
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter voilà en quelques mots
l'histoire de cette chocolaterie la
chocolaterie existe depuis maintenant
fin personnellement ça fait une
trentaine d'années qu'on est installé
sur Orléans et donc la chocolatière
existe depuis
1982 exactement vous avez vu justement
évolué cette rue Jeanne d'Arc vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
c'était une rue très commerçante il y a
une trentaine d'années enfin elle y est
toujours mais c'est vrai que ça évolué
il y a eu le tram qui est qui est arrivé
il y a eu toute la zone piétonne et je
crois que cette chocolaterie c'est aussi
une histoire de femmes et de
transmission est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire partager justement cette histoire
depuis une dizaine d'années on a eu nos
deux enfants en garçon et fille qui ont
émis le souhait de venir nous retrouver
donc notre fils est revenue en
chocolaterie avec son père et puis ma
est revenu avec moi et on espère
effectivement un jour passé le flambeau
des femmes des hommes des chocolats de
la gourmandise ah oui c'est important
parce que la gourmandise est favorable à
la beauté donc voilà prenez soin de vous
et puis n'oubliez pas des fleurs des
cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même pas
peur
[Musique]